Glow stringing. We don't talk about it
nearly enough in the PO world. And yet,
PO spinners owe an enormous debt to the
glow stringers of the world. Glow
stringing is among the immediate
antecedants of modern-day PO spinning.
And we get a surprising array of tricks
from it. And in this video, I'm going to
share with you five tricks that we get
from the glow stringing world. Some of
which may come as a surprise to you.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm counting
down the top five tricks that we
borrowed from the glow stringing world.
Before we dive in though, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks go to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys,
Pyoter, Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video. And just to put a massive
thank you out there to Pekka Becklon for
having supported this channel for so
very long. I appreciate you and
everything that you've done these past
few years. Okay, so just the smallest
amount of background here. Modernday po
spinning has descended from a number of
different arts or takes inspiration from
them. Everything from traditional Maui
poi and kapahaka to contact juggling and
more recently toss juggling as well. But
one of those sources of inspiration is
one that we don't talk about all that
often. And that is glow stringing. That
is the art of spinning around glow
sticks on the end of shoelaces that came
about in the mid '90s rave scene and
blossomed in the early 2000s. Glow
stringing had some really unique
variables that impacted it as an art
form and its evolution. It's meant to be
performed in crowded spaces, so the prop
had to stay pretty close to the body,
and you couldn't open up into a lot of
volume, so you still had to come up with
stuff that looked really impressive.
Glow stringers had to get really
creative in how they would do that. Now,
there are no shortage of movement arts
around the world that involve just
swinging around an object on a flexible
tether. But what's different about glow
stringing is that it's really deeply
embedded into the DNA of present- day po
spinning. In fact, I'm willing to bet
you that a bunch of the tricks that we
get from glow stringing are ones that
you had no idea came from that source.
And I'm going to prove it right here.
So, let's dive in. Trick number one,
elbow and wrist wraps. So, these were
definitely a lot more common when I got
into poi back in the late 2000s. And you
would often see people on the firefield
who wore sleeves to be able to perform
those wraps without burning themselves.
Nearly everybody that I knew or took
inspiration from in my early years had
actually gotten started as a glow
stringer themselves. And it definitely
informed their styles and by extension
mine as well. Of course, when you're
starting off as a PO spinner, one of
those things that you wrestle with
constantly is changing the direction of
the poi. And everything from stalls to
pendulums are options. But I mean, I'll
be real with you. When I first learned
how to do wraps, they just seemed like
the easiest option and they were
something that I used constantly for
years as a result. And it does need to
be said, find a glow stringer who really
knows their way around wraps. You will
see some of the most impressive and
rapid spinning you have ever seen in
your life. I love it. But wrists and
elbows are not the only place where you
can either wrap a glow stick or your
poi. And in fact, there's going to be
quite a few wraps further on in this
list. Starting with
trick number two, shotguns.
So, full disclosure, I actually avoided
shotguns for most of my flow career. I
didn't really see the utility in them.
It kind of seemed antithetical to the
idea of spinning a prop that you wrap it
up to the point where it can no longer
spin. And then, as I got deeper into the
dance world, what I realized was it was
one of several options we have out there
for creating clean suspensions. And I
haven't looked back since. Shotguns
involve fully wrapping the tether all
the way around its native hand. This can
both immobilize a prop as well as change
the direction of it on the fly. And it
does have to be said, shotguns are
surprisingly versatile, whether it be
doing the suspensions that I mentioned
up top or immobilizing the prop and read
glow stick to kind of turn it into a
more traditional style of spinning glow
sticks. There's a lot to love here and I
think it's just a question of finding
which use is best for you. Of course,
dance focused as I am, I can't help but
also notice that when you perform
shotguns, you're also playing around
with volume. That is, you're going back
and forth between the prop at full
length and then at no length. And that
gives you a lot of dynamic
possibilities, too. So, give those
shotguns another look if it's been a
while. Yes, they can be difficult to do
on fire, but most of us aren't really
primarily doing this on fire at this
point, are we? Trust me, you'll thank me
later.
Trick number three, the Superman.
Yeah. So, I guess this is kind of a
wrap, too. Although it's a really
specialized one because it only goes
around our waist. The Superman or as it
was originally called the one-handed
Superman is a two-po trick that involves
rapid wraps that go around the waist as
well as a two beat weave that happens on
the thumb end. And man, I remember when
this trick blew up back circa 2010 or
2011. We had just had a huge influx of
glow stringers come into the poi world
and they brought this little gem with
them. And man, every po spinner wanted
to learn how to do it. Of course,
there's a whole family of tricks that
come along with it. I'm pretty sure both
the Superman and the Fantastic Four were
originally mapped out for glow stringers
before being brought over to PO. And it
has to be said, both of them are still
classics to this day, and I still see
them performed all the time. So, now
that we've wrapped around our wrists and
elbows, our hands and our waist, that's
got to be it, right? We're done with the
wraps on this list.
Well,
trick number four, spiral wraps.
Yeah. So, I'm betting if there is one
trick on this list that comes as at
least a little bit of a surprise to
those of you out there watching, it's
going to be this one. Spiral wraps have
been such an integral part of po
spinning for so long. I'm willing to bet
that most people who do them don't
realize they got started in the glow
stringing world. But if you know what to
look for, the providence of this trick
is really obvious. We're really just
performing shotguns with both of our
hands, but keeping our hands together as
that happens. This means that the prop
wraps around both hands instead of just
one. And I do think it has to be said
there is a reason why this trick is such
a classic both among po spinners and
glow stickers. Not only does it do that
same trick that shotguns do where we go
between small and large volumes, but
also for two different cultures that are
really into creating patterns, this
creates a really beautiful one. Those
spiral shapes are incredibly
eye-catching, and it's no wonder this
became such a mainstay of both arts. All
right, so after all that, you're either
totally over wraps or completely
expecting me to make the next trick on
this list also a rap based trick. But
it's not
trick number five, orbitals.
All right, so if you know, you know.
This one had to be on this list.
Orbitals have definitely fell out of
favor in the PO world, especially since
contact PO had become so incredibly
popular. Just the way that they're built
makes orbitals really difficult, if not
impossible to do. But I tell you, when I
was coming up, absolutely everybody was
doing orbitals constantly. You could not
spin a PO set without seeing somebody do
one of these. And it's a shame these
have fallen out of favor cuz they're so
beautiful. Really, this is a hyperloop
or tangle that you're speeding up by
pulling out on the handles, thus
reducing the radius of the circle that
the props are spinning around and
increasing the amount of angular
momentum. This means the PO go really,
really, really fast. The one problem
with orbitals is that they kind of
suffer from a hardware problem. You need
to have swivels or bearings pretty close
to the handle cuz the amount of torque
that happens on the tether will twist it
up into all kinds of ugly mess if you
don't. And unfortunately, they're really
the only trick that you can do with that
setup. And because of that, they fell
out of favor a long time ago. And I
think it's a shame cuz they look really
cool. And of course, all of us that have
wrestled with them know the pain of
trying to find the exit for an orbital.
Yes, it takes some practice, and yes,
there is always at least some chance to
it. But man, when you see somebody nail
both the orbital and the exit, you have
just seen some magic. So, those are my
picks for the top five tricks that PO
spinners have uh borrowed, shall we say,
from the glow stringing world. What did
you think of my list? Did I forget any
of your favorites? Leave me a comment
and let me know. Also, make sure to
like, share, and subscribe to help other
people find this video and to help my
channel grow. If you dug the glow
stringing throwback pair of poi I was
using in this video, these are Helix Poi
Pros from Ultra Poi. And you can get 10%
off your own set when you use the promo
code Drex Factor with a zero instead of
an O at checkout. Link down in the
description.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. And if you would like to get your
name in the credits or access to a host
of other awesome rewards, you can do
that by hitting up my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll include a link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. Check that out and help me out in
my mission to bring po spinning and flow
arts to the whole wide world. Thank you
in advance. It has been so long since I
have done a top five tricks video. But
if you like this, the good news is is
that there are a lot more where this
came from. I'll go ahead and include a
link to the playlist of them up here on
screen. Thank you so much for watching
this video. I hope you get out and flow
today and make use of at least one of
the tricks you saw here. Take care and
I'll see you with a new video real soon.
Peace.
[Music]